how's it going raise monies beer ah I
like you brother's vote on what the next
game was gonna be you bros voted and the
winner is you already read it in the
titles I don't know why I bother
infamous second son it was a very very
tight call between corpse party and this
one and to be honest I'm glad this one
won because I really want to do like I
said I really wanted to play it when
once it came out I just never had time
for it so it looks really cool and I'm
just really excited to play it if you
voted for court Friday don't worry we'll
probably do it eventually anyway but
first of all we're gonna do infamous
second son it's gonna be amazing girl
it's been a while since we did a series
on this channel and I'm very excited I'm
very excited it's been far too long this
is also the first next-gen game that I
play its first one I'm actually excited
to play to be honest old wireless
controller sideways okay oh my god I'm a
graffiti artist rattle oh this is
amazing
r2 just haha street art you don't get it
mommy's right
that's pretty cool actually haha that's
a fun idea came up with that lady all
right oh we got to get the hands too
I actually tried it spraying graffiti
once and I was pretty awful
you kept winning the bottle add this
paint or whatever
oh we had this as well not a lot of
juice in this one there we go
is that what I did didn't really look
okay this is amazing
next-gen has all led up to this there
wait what's worth it
this is awesome okay what's next
hell a card is a crime than just damn it
I like anything but subtitle dating
that's awesome like it's underwear party
the long house just got to get there
mingle establish an alibi I'm a goddamn
criminal mastermind now you left the
evidence oh I didn't matter
Salman Bey that sounds delicious right
genius uh-oh who's out there
she's just me ready oh won't you please
stapler down seriously huh
what are you doing here why did you
gonna kill me better thought long house
oh uh yeah I just didn't feel all that a
comas tonight but you look amazing it
looks great on you seriously what were
you doing up on the roof hmm nothing
just were you up to mischief come on I
know you're in there so just come on out
or I'll call Betty and she'll be here in
five minutes with the key you're up to
mischief
okay what come on seriously what are you
gonna do here look I have no choice he's
a cop I have to be back here in five
minutes and if you were still here
thanks Betty
this is the last time or she's gonna
staple my face to go back to my office
apparently I'm getting a phone call
and I get to move amazing anything
better to do gotta find another way back
door out of the fish cannery that's over
here isn't it let's take a shortcut oh
my god marriage parkour oh that's pretty
cool so I'm part of this Indian tribe
who does not know how to walk through
doors there we go managed hello freedom
it's beautiful now the easy part
get to the longhouse set up an alibi
really all this effort what if I just
did it properly the first time
all right that's cool oh oh oh [ __ ] it
then so how do we get over there let's
go here that's cool the controls are
very smooth and it looks gorgeous look
at I awesome up very cool
there's no battles even though we're at
a fish fishing plate that's amazing
wait I had it my week a - may we gg oh
Jesus crisis places crappy is big super
jump
nailed it haha good just stop doing that
doing what we're gonna climb sideways
yeah ah go crap here that shit's
corrosive fingers gonna fall off shoo
shoo shoo seagulls again shoo they're
not wearing shoes though I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry alright I'm a fricking
monkey ninja Jesus Christ this would
probably take me a year and I probably
die a million times if I didn't look
down don't look down don't look down
whoops oh my god we're dead and we did a
plan is working perfectly
the amazing plan what is this a college
days family fun amazing open the door
how swipe the touchpad what why
been looking like forever for you
probably just kids
I have any idea how embarrassing it is
for me to keep arresting my own brother
over and over and over Matt stop
arresting your brother over and over and
I think I get a joke no I know how you
want to leave your mark on the world huh
you think this would make our parents
proud misdemeanor vandalism semaine
there's a lot of scary [ __ ] in the world
and while I'm out there actually trying
to assert my tower triangle ah sir
you're Tommy always do this Reggie won't
you swing away what big bad experiment
there's brain it's really because I
don't seem too greedy what truck oh damn
that is a truck home any just drive
straight oh oh oh it's the bioterrorist
I'm going after those two you stay back
that thing's gonna blow
stay away from the exploding thing got
it sure Cheryl oh I'll just stay here
all right
so much fun okay fine survivors lights
let's check it out so - first rider need
some help hello sending my oh I got a
smile Jerry doing next-gen the game play
amazing you're welcome
oh thanks man I thought I was gonna die
are you all right what let him go
I was helping him no keep your hands
where I can see it is hurt nobody
I saw the Gulf will she get you I said
let him go or I will shoot you
right Oh who's one other buy it um you
should probably say no done that
what is happening
it's my beanie okay
oh thank god so now I have the power
I'm smoke rich oh I gotta find Reggie
oh they like their secrets oh Jesus
why didn't I do how was that what the
hell I don't know
okay what is this happening to me god no
I have the feeling the Akama stays oh
god he keeps going on is it safe to move
okay he keeps using it
oh my god make it stop Megan Fox good
roads I really need to can we use our
power to get through this
oh my god oh my god he needs our Han
smoke right smell of power
clatter you're smash mark Oh God Oh
Randy trees is not a problem like what
you okay no what you sitting there
I'm gonna get that thing off you that
looks adorable
I gotta get you out okay okay just tell
me push I get to swipe oh oh damn I got
something man I can't stop it
Rezac it's okay it's okay you're okay
breathe breathe all right I ship them so
much no no no my brother all right
you're my brother okay same with yours
gonna pass
I promise we'll fix it right here with
me
you with me okay you get out there there
is about us we gotta stop him before he
gets the rest the drive
I need you I need you right now right
okay yeah amazing I can't use it anymore
I can only use it where there's smoke I
guess makes sense right I wouldn't have
been able to even get to you back there
if I hadn't I can't use it hey hey he's
in here I don't want you to think what's
happened is is a good thing it's not the
buttons jammed
I think Betty's still inside she's
manolache is melt UPS I looked awkward
the hell he get through I think he ran
through oh you can do that only one way
to find out oh well I have my smoke
power rips that was fun wait cami what'd
you do whoa through the vent ass awesome
that's so cool
good to know Oh is he he just travels as
it okay that's all so that's really
[ __ ] cool well that should have hurt
she mean going here doesn't look too
good
what your your smoke man how did all
this happen at once and press to hit the
timber hot choc work damn I'm not gonna
spoil the surprise amazing okay me oh
I'll go stare Betty slap those wig get
out of here wait for me
dolphin what's going on here I was just
trying to create a diversion I didn't
know anybody was in here did this to me
you're a conduit ah Betty I'll explain
later but you got to get out of here now
brofist is face not until you fix this
first
but it's so cool why would he not like
it
oh he melts his face that's nice I spent
most of my life behind bars it's easy
enough to bust out
you just gotta wait for that golden
opportunity when I got my powers I'm a
parents hell I was unstoppable until the
DUP caught up with me yeah they got a
special hole they like to toss folks
like me in figured out a way to bind us
all up so we couldn't use our powers
that also meant they had to feed us
washes he'd wipe our goddamn asses son
awesome that's no way for a man to live
there's no way
if you can't wake her own ass I don't
wanna let redheaded [ __ ] they're really
in the needles and scalpels she called
what she did me tests
but if you do enough time you learn a
few tricks just gotta be patient sooner
or later they'll screw up they always do
you maybe see something or you hear
something learn things you weren't
supposed to know so when that [ __ ] put
the three of us and that wagon I knew
what was coming
a golden opportunity haha I've attended
him passing out of life
I saw you poking around inside my head
was me I thought that was me yet you saw
right get DUP prison she catches you
that's where you're going like wait wait
oh my god they won't let me keep my B in
the end there we're gonna fight why
warning you kid back off not going
anywhere till you fix this
it looks [ __ ] awesome I don't know
what happened but you better be ready to
disappear why O'Shea conduit now kids a
bioterrorist welcome to the world of run
for your life and that's what I aim to
do even if I gotta go through you okay
we're back
slap that [ __ ] with a chain so have the
chain around my oh there we go hmm taste
it now going anywhere tell you fix this
fish I jump Nick your beef fish Thanks
ah come on at least show me how to
control it
we've got job he seems like he's
controlling pretty well she knows I'm
onto a play okay maybe not he's even
taking damage
[ __ ] you three minutes conversion drop I
got a get now ain't going back to
curtain case yeah well whoever's colour
God for you man not me you've been
seeing some folks here know about you
she's got a way of making people talk
slap that [ __ ] your look hell no no way
I'm gonna die in a fish gunnery fish
country that's the worst place you could
ever die on slime pit Oh nobody's ever
gonna know about any of this that was
fast
wait a minute Stoppard's dog barking hey
became a troll oh I am so very
disappointed in you
well we got him right I flushed that
mean old conduit for you everybody
specially you got a terrorist Henry
Daughtry has a bioterror Oh condors he's
a word used my traitors sympathize with
their cause a year not no no he's a he's
a bioterrorist hey are you I uh try not
to be you seem nervous miss deer hair no
it's blinding me it's been my experience
there are only two reasons for people to
be nervous either they're cowards or
they have something to hide well you
know I also get nervous I was gonna say
ha ha ha ha you were in there with that
bioterrorist for some time did he share
anything with you oh sure did he say
anything to you share any of his
ramblings about
um no he didn't didn't share anything
not even his birthday cake that's good
to hear
I don't trust her she's gonna do
something weird you see we are engaged
in a life-and-death war with these bio
terrorists and it's my job to do
whatever it takes to ensure that we win
that war Hey
okay nice necklace what that's kind of
funny because aren't you a bioterrorist
ooh oh oh no he no no he didn't okay
yes
am sometimes you have to fight fire with
fire
and it's clear now that you're not a
coward which means there's something
that you're not now who's you crazy I've
got rights and I have a legal authority
to suspend those rights whenever I feel
it's necessary like now for instance
I'll ask again what happened in there
she reminds me of my old boss again oh
I'm told that hurts she can't just
penetrate me like that no Betty does so
really still nothing
don't touch Betty well unless you decide
that you dislike you really have to [ __ ]
I'll go chat with that nice old lady but
you should know concrete is especially
hard on brittle bones yeah and if she
doesn't talk I'll just move on to the
next one next time find someone who does
so do you have something you want to
tell me or do you prefer that I move on
to your friends here
is it is it decision time oh my god
I have to sacrifice the try why would I
sacrifice a tribe turn myself in oh god
that's a tough one oh god I can't make
decisions uh I turned myself in I
suppose poor Betty risking your freedom
to protect Betty it's a first step to
becoming a here man but what happens if
I sacrifice them putting others in
dangers to save yourself as a first step
to become infamous I mean the title of
the game is infamous Oh God we're gonna
have to turn ourselves in though just
look at that
Betty face if you want a Betty face you
got it sacrifice
but like I made the right call what I
said I'm a conduit alright
I caught it a second ago from from that
guy oh you caught it very funny
ah oh right in the back ow
so Betty maybe you can give me a
straight answer that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
say matter every time she says come up
with new material she's worse than me so
you it's kind of like I guess Mass
Effect or like renegade or I don't
remember where the other one was oh yeah
we're going with the weed protector so
far we'll see I think that's a great
part to end the first episode really
love it so far
awesome I really hope you bros are
excited for this playthrough as much as
I am thank you for showing your support
by leaving a like and leaving a comment
I really appreciate that especially
since this is the first episode that's
all for me I'll see you with a new one
tomorrow thanks for hanging out with me
today bros and stay awesome
brofist